[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prouvez nous quelqu'un dont maxime ou le
lycée marc boillot ne sera bien sûr on
aime beaucoup aimé à l'avancé votre
chanson préférée
ouais et c'est vrai et c'est vrai pour
une fois c'est vrai quoi pour eux c'est
pour énerver 20 tarbes à quoi je serais
malheureux alors je remets de mes
lauriers avec au programme ce soir une
énorme révélation sur le passé d'un et
chronique en touche pas à mon poste non
si c'est si vous allez voir des images
de ce corps qui ne sera jamais aux jeux
olympiques
une candidate de jeu un peu trop stressé
et surtout je vous dévoilais la photo
que tous les magazines people russie
d'avoir aujourd'hui sauf que c'est moi
qui l'ait vous allez voir c'est
incroyable alors c'est une série que si
je suis injoignable tous les jours entre
12h50 et 14h c'est parce que je dors
devant williams à midi alors j'adore mes
joueurs je reste dans la tête pour faire
au moins un téléspectateur
alors ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
fait un petit point williams vous êtes
déjà montré des exemples de thèmes très
chaud abordés dans cette émission est ce
que vous avez envie de faire un petit
point à mon avis oui j'adore ça alors
attention ça va secouer voici le laurier
de démission qui continue à traiter des
sujets de fond
à
comment est on peut recommencer ou valve
recommencer recommencer recommencer au
régime dont ils ont tous deux répété de
tous côtés arrêté tout est relancé
merci roland je l'aurais attention c'est
parti c'est parti comment bien choisir
sa brosse à dents top 10 de ce qu'il ne
faut pas mettre au micro-ondes habiller
son chien est ce nécessaire carafes
filtrantes ou mauvaise idée
non je suis mauvaise foi bien sûr que
parfois williams traite de ce vrai sujet
très sensible pomme de faire sauter
gratin dauphinois aligot
quel est le monde fait l'audience alors
je regarde très souvent la chaîne
l'équipe c'est une super chaîne n'y a
pas forcément les moyens de payer les
droits du foot ou du tennis
malheureusement alors ils ont décidé de
différer des sports dont personne ne
connaissait l'existence
cette semaine c'était les championnats
du monde de bûcheronnage oui bah oui ça
le but c'est d'être le plus rapide pour
scier du bois
alors oui on s'en fout mais les
commentateurs de cette compétition 100
foot aussi c'est ça qui fait rire alors
voici le laurier des commentateurs qui a
réussi à faire des vannes encore plus
pourri que nelson monfort et philippe
candeloro
[Musique]
parce que si rocky balboa l'américain
kogure valbois hausse seulement le
rappelle nous sommes nous à liverpool il
fait c'est pas tous les risques c'est
pas le type b ce soir c'est letizi est
un peu dur avec ge avec est dur avec
martin il s'y connaît le tchèque en bois
mais c'est de la merde oui des problèmes
je connais ces trucs là c'est pas
évident qu'ils seront bien sorti
franchement ils sont très bien sortis
alors on est motus ce matin je me suis
fait une réflexion si doc gynéco
participer à ce jeu il va appeler tous
les maux comme on ferait en fait saturer
3g très long oui j'ai entendu parler de
l'histoire de nina hagen
oui oui c'était très intéressant
vivacité vais y serait un petit peu
longue
or donc au dessus j'ai découvert une
candidate extraordinaire c'est une
certaine josette je vous êtes celle
inverse de doc gynéco c'est la personne
la plus stressée au monde jamais vu
quelqu'un jouer autant sa vie pour
trouver des mots elle est aussi tendue
que si le même jour elle passait le bac
le permis qu'elle avait un contrôle
fiscal
josette remporté le laurier de la
candidate qui s'est mis une pression de
ouf
juste pour gagner 50 euros à motus
visiteuse mais cité u s es
[Musique]
soleil has fce
alors on touche pas à mon poste on a la
chance de recevoir des invités hyper
sympa ouais très souvent ils rient aux
éclats avec toute leur vie de dark actes
sur ce plateau mais parfois ya des
vannes qui font rire tout le monde sauf
l'invité notamment notre ami olivier
dion que telle à la semaine dernière il
est aidé parce qu'il est évident il est
comme ça mais il n'a pas apprécié n'y a
pas compris peut-être un des jeux de
mots dont vous avez le génie cyril c'est
dingue pour sa tête qu'il fait olivier
dion je lui remets le leur et d'invités
qui est hermétique aux vagues de cyril
hanouna est en fait il était arrivé
quelque chose à khaled
oui un petit souci la criirad est pas
bien alors leur histoire il est temps de
la révélation lundi soir dans des
cinémas pornos de paris a fermé ses
portes
alors avant les gens adorent et regarder
les films pour adultes en groupes c'est
un peu salissant mais bon maintenant les
gens préfèrent regarder les films tout
seul sur internet et bfm paris a fait un
reportage sur la fermeture de ce cinéma
et j'ai fait une découverte qui va vous
estomaqué cyril ça concerne le passé de
quelqu'un que vous connaissez tous très
bien aussi le laurier du chroniqueur qui
a bien caché son jeu pendant des années
un homme révèle désormais c'est fini le
beverley c'était son nom il a fermé sept
à la fermer définitivement ses portes
et regardez ce que j'ai découvert sur le
mur des souvenirs de cinéma la fiche de
films et valérie bénaïm touche mais
boulettes à hammamet
ah si je vous assure voilà c'est
terrible
[Applaudissements]
ce soir on sait pas ce qu'elle tourne en
ce moment alors il est temps d'en venir
à la photo que tout le monde attendait
évidemment bien sûr essayer de l'avoir
mais je suis le seul à la détenir alors
tous les soirs sur ce plateau n'a le
meilleur public du monde ça sert à faire
et ce soir on m'a raconté que tous les
spectateurs voulaient absolument
s'asseoir de ce côté là alors que ça
m'arrive jamais d'habitude absolument
alors en fait c'est parce qu'hier les
gens de ce côté-là avait non seulement
vu sur les missions mais aussi vu sur
une partie intime de chroniqueur acide
ce côté non non dans un hôtel on peut
avoir l'option vue sur mer atp un pays à
désormais l'option vue sur la rai oui
oui vous allez voir alors j'ai la photo
de la reine un chroniqueur
manifestement si ce pourquoi ils
rigolent la fin est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à voir ce que vaut actuellement
tous côtés du public
oui on est prêtes et bien après l'arrêt
à kader voici l'art et à doc gynéco
[Applaudissements]